>> ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE
ELITES' MISPLACED
PRIORITIES.
AMERICAN KIDS SUFFER FROM
CONSEQUENCES OF LOCKDOWN.
RANDY WEINGARDEN IS
SHOWING UP WHERE, IN
UKRAINE.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SECOND LARGEST TEACHERS
UNION, JETTING TO THE WAR
TORN COUNTRY AFTER AN
INVITE FROM A UKRAINIAN
TEACHERS UNION, TWEETING
SHE WAS GOING TO ASSESS
THE DAMAGE LEFT OVER AFTER
RUSSIAN AIR STRIKES, EVEN
THOUGH PRETTY SURE SHE HAS
NO TRAINING TO DO THAT
WHATSOEVER.
LET ME GET IT STRAIGHT.
CLASSROOMS TOO DANGEROUS
FOR TEACHERS TO GO INTO
PAST TWO YEARS, BUT A WAR
ZONE IS NOT OFF LIMITS.
>> OUR TRIP IN SOLIDARITY
AND WITNESS IS PROBABLY
MORE IMPORTANT TODAY THAN
WHEN WE PLANNED IT, SO THE
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED.
CHILDREN ARE LEARNING
REMOTELY OR IN PERFECTS
NOW.
BUT UNION LEADERSHIP WANTS
TO IMMEDIATE WITH US, AND
WE WANT TO MEET WITH THEM,
SO WE'RE ON OUR WAY TO
LVIV.
>> FROM A COMMUNICATIONS
PERSPECTIVE, DOES THIS
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, NO, IT
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE.
I'LL LET JESSICA TRY TO
DEFEND IT.
SEE HOW SHE DOES.
JUST KIDDING.
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING
EDUCATION IS AN ISSUE IN
THE MIDTERMS, THIS IS THE
YEAR OF THE PARENT.
WE SUGGESTED DEMOCRATS
DISTANCE FROM PEOPLE LIKE
RANDY WIN
EINGARDENW
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAPPENED TO SOMEBODY
LIKE A TIM RYAN IN OHIO,
SO THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING THEIR POSITION, ONE
OF THE REASONS TULSI
GABBARD WANTED TO LEAVE
THE PARTY IS YOU'RE EITHER
FOR ALL OF THE THINGS THE
DEMOCRATS STAND FOR OR YOU
CAN'T BE WITH US.
AND IF YOU SAY WELL, THE
TEACHERS UNION SEEMED TO
HAVE TOO MUCH POWER, I
THINK I DON'T LIKE THIS
LITTLE BIT OR THIS LITTLE
BIT, ALL OF A SUDDEN
YOU'RE THEN OSTRACIZED.
TIM RYAN IN OHIO HAS RUN A
PRETTY COMPETITIVE RACE
AGAINST JD VANCE, BUT HE
IS PULLING AWAY BECAUSE HE
WON'T PUT EDUCATION
RESOURCES INTO OHIO.
IT IS STILL ON THE BALLOT
IN UKRAINE.
>> IF YOU OVERSEE TWO
STRAIGHT YEARS OF
PLUMMETING TEST SCORES,
YOU LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
>> WHY NOT ASSESS THE
DAMAGE HERE THAT YOU
CREATED.
UKRAINE NEEDS A
BATTLESHIP, NOT A BATTLE
AX, A SEXIST WOULD SAY.
THIS IS A WEIRD TREND,
RIGHT?
SHE MUST HAVE A PR
CONSULTANT, IF YOU WANT TO
BURNISH YOUR PUBLIC
PERSONA, GO TO UKRAINE.
DID THIS WITH BEN STILLER,
IS CUOMO.
>> AS LONG AS YOU ARE IN
UKRAINE.
>> SHAMELESSLY INCOMPETENT
BUREAUCRAT OUT FOR
HERSELF.
GO TO UKRAINE.
THE NEW VERSION OF GOING
TO CUBE A REMEMBER PEOPLE
WERE GOING TO CUBA AND
DOING A VACATION OR
HONEYMOON THERE.
THE HEAD OF TEACHERS UNION
ISN'T IN IT FOR THE
TEACHERS AND THE KIDS, IT
IS IN IT FOR HERSELF.
THIS IS OBVIOUS.
IT HELPS NO ONE BUT
HERSELF.
>> I BET YOU DIDN'T KNOW
THIS, JUDGE, THIS IS
RANDY'S SECOND TIME IN
UKRAINE THIS YEAR.
>> WHY ARE SO MANY
DEMOCRATS GOING TO
UKRAINE?
WHY DO WE SEND SO MUCH
MONEY THERE, ALL THE
DEMOCRATS SHOW UP IN
UKRAINE.
JUST A QUESTION I'M
THROWING OUT THERE.
>> CAN I ANSWER?
>> WHY DON'T YOU FIGURE IT
OUT.
LOOK, SHE'S GOING THERE TO
BEAR WITNESS TO SCHOOLS
BEING CLOSED AND AREAS
BEING BOMBED, KIDS ARE
BEING KILLED.
SHE WANTS TO ASSESS THE
REMOTE LEARNING OF KIDS
LIVING UNDER BUILDINGS AND
BUNKERS.
THAT'S BUNK.
I AM TELLING YOU.
THERE'S ANOTHER REASON,
SHE'S HEADING TO THE
BORDER TO ASSESS SITUATION
OF THE RUSSIAN ATTEMPTS TO
FRIGHTEN CIVILIANS AND THE
EFFECT ON CHILDREN.
I'M JUST GOING TO REPEAT
WHAT GREG SAID.
WHY AREN'T YOU WORRIED
ABOUT AMERICAN CHILDREN
WHO LOST MORE GROUND IN
THE LAST 30 YEARS -- IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS THAN IN
THE LAST 30 YEARS.
OUR OWN SCHOOLS ARE
UNDERSTAFFED.
YOU HAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
YOU CAN'T EVEN PUT AIR
CONDITIONING IN, LET ALONE
CREATE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
DURING COVID.
I AM DISGUSTED WITH THEM
ALL, WITH THE ELITISTS
THINKING I, THE FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS, NEED TO GO TO
EUROPE TO ASSESS THE
RUSSIAN'S IMPACT ON
CHILDREN THERE.
ARE THERE ANY CHILDREN
THERE?
>> THIS WOULD BE LIKE
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS WENT
TO PUERTO RICO TO ASSESS
THE DAMAGE IN PUERTO RICO.
WHY DOESN'T HE JUST STAY
IN THIS COUNTRY AND FIX
IT.
>> RANDY WEINGARDEN?
>> YES, WHY IS SHE IN
UKRAINE.
IT WAS AN ANALOGY.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT IS NOT
JUST DEMOCRATS IN UKRAINE,
THEY'RE HOSTING A NUMBER
OF -- WHAT WE'RE DOING,
MOST OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS FOR REPUBLICANS.
THE INVITATION CAME FROM
THE UKRAINIAN TEACHERS
UNION.
>> DO YOU GO TO EVERY
PARTY YOU'RE INVITED TO?
>> NO.
>> ARE UKRAINIAN TEACHERS.
>> CAN I FINISH?
LET ME FINISH THE
SENTENCE.
I THINK A VIDEO ADDRESS
FOR THIS KIND OF THING
WOULD HAVE DONE.
SCHOOL IS IN SESSION.
IT IS ALSO VERY DIFFERENT
THAN IF YOU GO, WHENEVER
SHE WENT OVER THE SUMMER,
KIDS ARE BACK IN SCHOOL,
BEEN ABOUT A MONTH NOW.
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO.
LITERACY SCORES WERE
TERRIBLE.
WE HAVE FUNDING ISSUES AND
ALL OF THIS MONEY THAT
CAME IN FROM AMERICAN
RESCUE ACT THAT NEEDS TO
BE ALLOCATED AND SPENT
PROPERLY.
OBVIOUSLY IT LOOKS
TERRIBLE.
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING THE
IMPACT ON THE NEVADA
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST
INDEPENDENT TEACHER UNIONS
THAT ENDORSED THE
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR IN THE
LAST ELECTION IS NOT
ENDORSING ANYBODY.
IT IS BECAUSE NOTHING WAS
DONE AFTER NEGATIVE
EFFECTS OF COVID.
THAT'S A VERY BIG DEAL.
>> DIDN'T WE SPOT HER AT
THE JAMES TAYLOR CONCERT
AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> YEAH.
>> SHE GOES TO EVERYTHING.
>> SHE HAS A FULL DANCE
CARD.
>> SHE DOES.
BET SHE CAN'T DANCE.